wo ist hilal ercan seit dem 27 januar
1999 ist die damals zehnjährige wie vom
erdboden verschwunden
seit mittlerweile mehr als 22 jahren
arbeiten die ermittler mit hochdruck an
dem fall
im jahr 2005 die plötzliche wende spur
380 führt die ermittler zu einem
tatverdächtigen wird ist ein
sexualstraftäter
verurteilt wegen kindesmissbrauchs
dauerhaft untergebracht in einer
psychiatrischen einrichtung
er gesteht viele getötet und im
hamburger volkspark keine drei kilometer
vom wohnhaus entfernt
vergraben zu haben
er führt die ermittler zu dieser stelle
im wald doch gefunden wird nichts
stellen sie sich das vor ihre tochter
kommt super glücklich nach hause
mit einem extrem guten zeugnis und
natürlich freuen sie sich mit ihr
schenken ihr vielleicht ein bisschen
geld mit dem geld will sich ihre tochter
dann kaugummis kaufen und verschwindet
dabei spurlos taucht abtaucht nie wieder
auf niemand weiß was geschehen ist
genauso geht es den eltern von hilal
ercan seit 22 jahren wissen sie nicht
was mit ihrer tochter geschehen ist
wurde die kleine hielt verschleppt wurde
sie ermordet und sah reporter jan henrik
thomas d hat sich auf spurensuche
begeben
die kleine hilal ercan im alter von zehn
jahren ein fröhliches mädchen eine gute
schülerin aus dem hamburger stadtteil
lurup und die ihr ganzes leben noch vor
sich hat seit dem 27
januar 1999 seit mittlerweile mehr als
zwei jahrzehnten ist die kleine hier
verschwunden dieses verbrechen berührt
seit 22 jahren die menschen in
deutschland kann
und immer wieder kommt man zu dieser
frage zurück wie kann denn ein kleines
mädchen 50 meter von ihrem zuhause
einfach so verschwinden
seit 22 jahren lebt die familie in
ungewissheit wurde healey verschleppt
wurde sie getötet was ist mit ihr
geschehen
fragen an den täter die die familie seit
hier lights verschwinden quellen
[Musik]
hat jederzeit die möglichkeit jeden tag
aufs neue was uns zu sagen und ich
glaube noch an ihn dass er das mir sagt
persönlich und darauf wartet
[Musik]
wenn jemand
etwas beobachtet hat etwas zu sagen hat
dann möge sich melden auch um frieden
für diese familie beziehen
[Musik]
besteht ein mann die tat und widerruft
wenig später sein geständnis wieder
können die ermittler bis heute das
schicksal von hinein nicht klären
das problem in diesem fall ist es
gewesen dass wir hingegangen sind und
flächendeckend gesucht haben aber nichts
gefunden haben und sich deshalb eben
nach wie vor nicht sagen lässt ist das
ein schwätzer oder
oder erzählt er die wahrheit
der fall hilal ercan ist einer der
mysteriösesten und spektakulärsten
vermisstenfälle deutschlands auch für
bild reporter jan henrik dumas am
verschwinden hilal ercan zu berichten er
und die reporter aus der hamburger
bildredaktion vom ersten tag an kleine
halle wo bist wir haben angst um unsere
kinder
kleine kinder
jetzt zeigt drei monaten verschwunden
als reporter werden wir natürlich auch
nicht aufhören darüber zu berichten das
ziel ist es bis dieser fall
abgeschlossen ist da an diesem fall dran
zu bleiben und auch nicht aufzugeben
immer wieder an diesem fall zu erinnern
staatsanwaltschaft hamburg seit mehr als
zwei jahrzehnten beschäftigt der fall
hilal ercan auch die polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft bis heute ist hilal
ercan das einzige langzeit vermisste
kind der hansestadt
diesem konkreten fall ist immer so
gewesen dass sich als staatsanwalt ein
halbes jahr nach der tatbegehung ganz
stark in diesem fall involviert worden
bin und tatsächlich ist es so dass mich
dieser fall auch in den letzten 20
jahren die ich losgelassen hat
[Musik]
die erbbau passage im hamburger
stadtteil und das wohnhaus der familie
ercan nur 50 meter durch eine straße von
dem ort entfernt an dem viele zuletzt
lebend gesehen wurde
ist mittwoch der 27 januar 1999 der
letzte schultag vor den winterferien
als vater und seine tochter und diesen
tag von der schule ab stolz zeigt sie
ihrem vater ihr zeugnis
gemeinsam machen sie sich auf den weg
nach hause für ihre besonderen
leistungen ihren fleiß in der schule
bekommt von ihrem vater als belohnung
noch eine demo es ist ungefähr 13 15 als
ziele die wohnung im achten stock
verlässt dann geht sie in richtung
capcom passage vermutlich um ihr
lieblings kaugummi zu kaufen die
zeugenaussagen belieben unstreitig ist
ja dass viele an dem besagten tag ihr
wohnhaus was mir gegenüber ist verließ
dann in diese passage er reingegangen
ist diese passage sind verschiedene
ladenzeilen da gab es zwei geschäfte wo
sie einen kaugummi den sie gerne mochte
huber mit der markt die sie von ihrem
vater vom zeugnis geld bekam hätte
kaufen können aber eben auch im
rückwärtigen teil des gebäudes ein
schwimmbad wo eben auch ein kiosk war so
irgendwo muss sie das gekauft haben von
einem gemüsehändler der die erbschafts
kennt wird vielleicht noch auf dem
parkplatz gesehen
ihre mutter findet dort später eine
haarspange und einen
vielleicht
zeiten wo einen großen rot blonden mann
der eine schwarzhaarige kind in sein
auto gezerrt haben soll bis heute will
die polizei darum wissen wer hat ihn am
mittwoch 27 erst 1999 gegen 13 15 in der
umgebung der fv passage gesehen
muss man natürlich noch mal sehen 1999
ist was anderes als
2021 wir haben heute einen öffentlichen
raum der an jeder ecke
kameraüberwachung enthält und hätten
wenn das heute passieren würde viel viel
nachhaltigere möglichkeiten
zu suchen nach dem mädchen nach einem
möglichen täter
aber es ist schon bemerkenswert
13.15 verschwindet ein mädchen in einer
innenstadt in einer innenstadt einer
großstadt und
niemand ist irgendwas aufgefallen
bild berichtete nach bekanntwerden des
verschwindens über den fall es folgen
bundesweite aufrufe dass kinder
verschwinden passiert häufig dass sie
verschwunden bleiben ganze
auf die verzweifelte familie von hilal
wendet sich immer wieder an die
öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
unsere hindernis ist ist am 27 der erste
verschwunden wir wünschen uns so sehr
dass sie gefunden wird ihr könnt nicht
sehr willkommen
[Musik]
helfen sie uns alle unsere kleine hilfe
zu finden
[Musik]
schon kurz nach bekanntwerden des
verschwindens von hier startet die
polizei eine der größten
fahndungsaktionen in der hamburger
polizei geschichte hundertschaften der
bereitschaftspolizei
suche nach der vermissten hilal ercan
vergeblich wenn kinder verschwinden dann
geht die polizei
von einer absoluten prioritäten lager
aus solche fälle werden
am besten in den ersten stunden nach dem
verschwinden geklärt weil natürlich dann
immer noch die hoffnung besteht dass man
die entführte das kind leben findet
sechs tage nach verschwinden kommt
plötzlich bewegung in den fall ein
anonymer anrufer meldet sich telefonisch
bei heel als eltern die nummer hat der
unbekannte vermutlich von selbst
gefertigten fahndungsplakaten der
familie
hier an der christuskirche im hamburger
stadtteil eimsbüttel will sich der mann
mit den eltern treffen um ihnen etwas
wichtiges mitzuteilen
als die eltern hier ankam wie viel ein
größerer polizeieinsatz und mutmaßlich
der mann der hier her kommen wollte wie
es das treffen platzen man muss sagen
bis heute natürlich würden sich die
ermittler wünschen dass derjenige der
damals meldete sich noch mal an die
polizei wenden sollte um das mitzuteilen
was er eben damals auf den eltern
mittragen wollte
wo ist hilal ercan seit dem 27 januar
1999 ist die damals zehnjährige wie vom
erdboden verschwunden seit mittlerweile
mehr als 22 jahren arbeiten die
ermittler mit hochdruck an dem fall
im jahr 2005 die plötzliche wende spur
380 führt die ermittler zu einem
tatverdächtigen wird ist ein
sexualstraftäter
verurteilt wegen kindesmissbrauchs
dauerhaft untergebracht in einer
psychiatrischen einrichtung
er gesteht viele getötet und im
hamburger volkspark keine drei kilometer
vom wohnhaus entfernt vergraben zu haben
er führt die ermittler zu dieser stelle
im wald doch gefunden wird nichts
wir haben diesen mann nachdem er das
gesagt hat dass das anderen gestanden
hat haben wir ihn vernommen der
vernehmung hat er die tat bestritten und
dass ich immer so weiter danach hatte
das wieder wieder anderen leuten erzählt
dass das gemacht hat wir haben ihn
wiederfand und letztmalig noch 2018 und
uns gegenüber sagte immer er ist es
nicht gewesen hier ist es letztlich so
dass wir nichts anderes haben als diese
teilweise widersprüchlich aber immer
wiederkehrende selbstbezichtigung dieses
mannes das reicht nicht aus um ihn
anzuklagen
nach der hoffnung der rückschlag alle
hinweise sind abgearbeitet und an spuren
überprüft der fall hilal ercan wird zum
cold case
die längerer zeit verstreicht desto
schwieriger wird das und heute gehen
alle mit der sache beschäftigen
fachleute davon aus dass sein herz schon
damals zu tode gekommen ist ohne dass
wir bis heute den leichnam entdeckt
haben sie wissen ja mord verjährt nicht
es gibt also auch an rechtlichen grund
dafür das ist ein nicht loslässt
[Applaus]
das jahr 2018 mittlerweile wurde im fall
hilal ercan eine cold case einheit
gegründet an der passage dem ort des
verschwindens der damals zehnjährigen
hilal befestigen ermittler der hamburger
polizei eine tafel als dauerhafte
fahndungspannen
[Applaus]
wir erhoffen uns die menschen zu
erreichen die eben die medien bisher
nicht so verfolgt haben sei es
printmedien oder auch ihre medien und
versuchen die letzte lücke zu schließen
der information und nutzen auf jeden
fall jede chance wirklich jede chance
noch zeugen des vorfalls hier auf dem
parkplatz zu bekommen drei jahre später
wird von der staatsanwaltschaft eine
belohnung für jeden fall die zur
ermittlung des täters führen von 5000
auf 20.000 euro angehoben im juni dieses
jahres teil daraufhin ein anonymer
anrufer der polizei mit am tag von hier
verschwinden
beobachtungen an der ecke passage
gemacht zu haben
die polizei ruft den unbekannten nun auf
sich nochmal zu melden es gebe weitere
fragen an den mann
die familie von hilal wendet sich
zuletzt 2018 in einem offenen brief an
den vermeintlichen täter
bitte sagen sie uns wo unser kleines
mädchen ist wir haben keine kraft mehr
bitte teilen sie ihr geheimnis mit uns
wir wollen doch nur unser kleines
mädchen wieder haben die
familie die ermittler und die
bild-reporter sie alle geben hier nicht
auf sie alle wollen gewissheit da wir
kein grab haben und alles versuchen dass
wir noch einen crêpe wenn man eine
schwester bekommen können sieht dabei
ordentlich zu bestatten zu können und
mit würde zu verabschieden das ist mein
ziel das wir diese hohe nicht bekommen
werde ich auch nicht locker lassen und
alles versuchen dass der täter und wo
sie sich befindet und das ist uns bis
heute schuldig klar der reporter wunsch
ist natürlich irgendwann darüber zu
berichten dass irgend jemand
festgenommen wird dass der mensch der so
eine tat begangen hat der einer familie
jahrelanges leid angetan hat dass der
der gerechtigkeit zugeführt wird und
dass der rechtsstaat in vor ein gericht
stellen kann und damit dies geschieht
will die polizei aktuell wissen wer kann
etwas zum verbleib dieser kleidung oder
dieser gegenstände sagen
wer erinnert sich an einen mann der am
januar 1999 in der nähe der lv passage
an einem pkw stand oder den eindruck
vermittelte auf jemanden zu warten wer
hat am dritten februar 1999 bei familie
erdogan angerufen und sich an der
u-bahn-haltestelle
christuskirche in hamburg eimsbüttel zu
treffen zudem bittet die polizei den
mann der sich am 23 juni 2021 um 10 uhr
drei telefonisch bei der polizei
gemeldet hat sich erneut zu melden
und wenn uns jemand helfen kann wenn
jemand
etwas beobachtet hat etwas zu sagen hat
dann möge sich melden auch um frieden
für diese familie zu produzieren
täter mitwisser oder zeugen melden sie
sich bei der hamburger polizei
damit aus dem cold case hilal ercan nach
22 jahren ein aufgeklärter fall
[Musik]
ja es ist ein fall der wirklich ans herz
geht seit 22 jahren hofft die familie
darauf endlich zu erfahren was mit ihrer
tochter geschehen ist wenn sie doch noch
etwas wissen was das leid von reits
familie endlich beenden kann dann melden
sie sich bei der polizei hamburg unter
4286 56789